tout le monde vous connaît mais on vous
connaît peu on va parler de vous et de
votre vie
alors votre vrai nom c'est Didier
Morville vous êtes né l'adresse quand
même non
Didier
dans une cité de la Seine-Saint-Denis
votre père assis racine comme comme
homme
j'ai fait une chanson d'ailleurs qui
s'appelle laisse pas traîner de ton fils
pour lui parler
ce que j'ai donc après après comme je
disais l'enfant donc pour lui parler
c'est un peu tard maintenant
votre mère aussi vous l'avez retrouvé
assez tardivement
quand on vous disait qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire quand tu seras grand vous
répondiez quoi je répondais pas
j'avais pas vraiment d'idée donc voilà
en 82 vous avez un choc vous avez 20 ans
vous allez au Trocadéro et vous
découvrez de jeunes Américains qui
dansent le smurf au son d'un ghetto
blaster c'est le début du hip-hop vous
rencontrez cool chaîne à ce moment-là
beaucoup de chaînes en fait il habitait
de l'autre côté de l'avenue moi j'ai été
d'un côté lui de l'autre donc c'était
déjà faire moi j'étais comme tous les
banlieusards à l'époque on montait sur
Paris disait-on et puis voilà pour aller
voir ce que font les autres quoi
et quand vous dansez tous les deux dans
le métro vous gagnez du pognon non un
petit peu
des miettes
et ça marchait non tous les deux dans le
métro au Châtelet-les-Halles
gens qui font la manche ça marche bien
ça ça il subvienne quoi ouais vous
gagnez plus que votre père par exemple
non je faisais autre chose pour gagner
plus que mon père ah voilà alors en 84
donc c'est la fin de l'émission de
Sydney et en fait le graffiti remplace
un peu le smurf la breakdance dans le
mouvement hip-hop c'est ça ouais le
graffiti c'est un truc en fait enfin
l'ami de Kool Shen il avait un livre
d'histoire-géographie avec une toute
petite photo comme ça d'un métro pain à
New York
ça nous avait un passage ça ouvert le
store quoi vous êtes parti là-dedans
quoi ouais ouais on a commencé à pisser
dans les coins et puis après sur les
gens alors au départ ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est Ken TM c'était un groupe de
tagueurs en 86 avant d'être un groupe de
chanteurs et puis un jour vous
rencontrez dixtre humaine et Johnny Go
et il vous disent le tag c'est de la
merde c'est le rap qui est au top vous
confirmez
ils essaient de nous expliquer qu'on
fait de la merde et qu'on est des merdes
c'est plus comme ça
et nous
nous les prenons pas pour pas grand pour
pas grand chose aussi à l'époque
en sédition on va leur répondre et on a
été créé notre premier texte dans la
cuisine de mon père de leur montrer que
on pouvait le faire nous aussi les
grands
alors est-ce que c'est vrai
que votre maison de disque épique vous a
suggéré un moment que NTM qui veut dire
nique ta mère ça signifie le Nord
transmet le message non jamais jamais
moi je peux je peux prétendre un truc
c'est que je peux partir je crois des
rares groupes peut-être du seul groupe
en France qui a jamais présenté une
maquette avant de faire un album quoi
s'il vous plaît NTM ça vous plaît bien
parce qu'elle est toute seule parce
qu'elle est quoi
c'est un bon parti parce que moi aussi
penser quoi du rap français en général
Justin
c'est comme tout il y a humour et humour
c'est pas important
en plus parce que parce qu'il a un côté
caustique nous on est des hooligans
derrière tu fais bien de prendre des
pincettes parce que je peux t'éclater
alors essaye de mesurer ton propos parce
que ça peut aller très vite quand même
je répondrai tout de suite la violence
tu as vu la violence moi voilà ça c'est
l'exemple
je trouve un peu trop virulent pour la
télé
ouais non je disais c'était quoi la
question c'est le rap français c'est
vous avez dit à khenaton il peut aller
se toucher Doc Gynéco c'est du plastique
sans consistance est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas dire finalement vous faites un peu
du gangsta rap et que les autres font du
rap normal moi je suis pas un gang non
mais gangsta rap ça veut dire qu'on a un
gangster obligatoirement bah un peu un
peu d'accord
je suis plus dans une catégorie ou c'est
le constat d'une certaine urgence en
fait voilà qu'on développe quoi mais
mais en aucun cas je cherche à me faire
passer pour un Bondy ou je pense que
déjà déjà c'est manqué de respect aux
gens qui font ça et qui sont sous le
coup de nécessaire comme on dit
nécessité fait loi je pense qu'il y a
des gens qui font ça ils te font pas le
choix qu'on parle d'autre choix qu'on
parle d'autres routines non plus pour
pouvoir s'en sortir
donc déjà et puis ces gens là moi je les
ai vu vivre je sais ce que c'est aussi
donc par rapport à ça j'ai aucun droit
de me réclamer gangster oui ou autre
quoi je fais de la musique donc j'ai
cette chance là quoi vous n'êtes pas
très très chaud sur la France vous avez
déclaré le FN est dissout mais les
racistes restent ah c'est moi qui ai dit
je sais pas si je parle comme ça mais
allons-y je sais pas on est toujours
direct si vous on est toujours dans le
même pays collabo ils ont sorti les
drapeaux qu'une fois les Américains
arrivaient d'ailleurs en ce moment on a
qu'à regarder la télé quoi c'est plein
de jeux jeter les mines je dis en coin
que tu es sur ta papa et ensuite donc ça
plaît quoi donc ça veut dire qu'on est
bien dans un pays de collabo quoi puis
moi je suis pas très problème c'est que
moi je viens mes parents viennent des
colonies moi je suis né ici quoi mais et
puis on a pas oublié qu'on est venu nous
chercher et puis que la France est un
pays cosmopolite donc il y a un moment
donné
moi j'ai 34 ans je paye beaucoup
d'impôts on fait encore sentir que je
suis pas forcément à ma place bon il y a
peut-être quelque chose qui va pas quoi
et que c'est déjà c'est le fait que j'ai
une tête cramé ça joue quoi
puis elle sourit aussi
est-ce que j'ai l'impression Joey Stark
malgré votre succès vous avez du mal à
vous sortir de la banlieue votre enfance
vous dites le sac à dos de la banlieue
il reste accroché à toi mon univers il
est là quoi je pense que si on sort de
ça je sais pas si j'ai encore des outils
pour
moi je suis je pense que je suis là
parce qu'il y a une raison d'être je
veux dire par j'ai un média dans les
mains donc j'en profite pour représenter
comme je le peux la majorité silencieuse
donc c'est surtout ça en fait mon combat
quoi et ouais j'habite encore là à côté
parce que je m'en fous quoi d'être
ailleurs pour le moment quoi j'ai besoin
d'aimer surtout quoi c'est à dire c'est
mon essence quoi et puis des fois Joey
Starr vous péter un peu les plombs
[Applaudissements]
alors on va pas faire le listing de tous
vos ennuis avec la justice mais
c'est vrai que vous avez souvent
l'occasion de vous affronter à vos
contemporains
j'arrive devant chez j'arrive devant
chez Sony et puis je sais plus ce qu'il
y avait eu dans l'entrevue que ces
gens-là que je dirigeais à l'époque vous
saviez plus qu'il y avait mais moi je
sais ce qu'il y avait moi j'étais avec
mon ami Béatrice et puis des gens nous
ont sauté dessus et puis dans l'entrevue
j'ai vu carrément on était drogué un
truc à notre super anodin quoi carrément
il y avait une page complète sur une
page complète il y avait deux lignes de
vrais c'est à dire qu'on était dans la
rue Béatrice et moi j'ai tout ce qui
était vrai le reste c'était que donc
entrevue c'était des interviews donc
c'était l'interview du mec qui vous
aviez ouvert
le crâne qui disait dis-moi il m'a
ouvert le crâne ouais mais je pense que
je pense que c'est curieux des choses il
y a des crânes intéressants à voir de
l'intérieur
c'est tout à fait ça alors pour raconter
l'histoire pour revenir au truc je pense
que je pense que même si entre vu c'est
un journal de merde il faut savoir une
chose c'est que quand même fait du
pseudo journaliste donc
ce journaliste
de journaliste mais il y a journalisme
ce qui veut dire que au moins un minimum
on se rencard quoi minimum et quand on
se regarde c'est juste je sais pas
savoir ce qu'il y a sur un PV comme
cette journaliste pouvait le savoir je
pense et sur le PV il y a quand même
marqué qu'il y a trois personnes qui me
sautent dessus je suis tout seul avec ma
copine maintenant si c'est moi après qui
passe pour l'agresseur c'est quand même
assez bizarre quoi comme truc donc le
fait que vous ayez écrit ça et je vous
connaissais pas en plus
j'ai demandé pendant je sais pas pendant
un quart d'heure en le suivant dans la
rue s'il connaissait ma ganache
pour savoir de quoi il parlait s'il me
connaissait en fait et c'est ce qui lui
a fait peur ce jour-là si je m'étais
écouté j'aurais joué au football avec
lui je l'ai pas fait
parce que je le fais pas
parce qu'il faut dire la vérité c'est
qu'un mec qui est passé en bagnole qui a
vu que j'allais me faire assassiner sur
place qui m'a recueilli dans sa voiture
j'ai mis deux gros coup de pied dans la
dans la bagnole les portières étaient en
creux comme ça le mec s'est arrêté 800
mètres plus loin et je lui dis je suis
sorti de la voiture tu voulais que je
vous rembourse pour la portière elle m'a
dit non non c'est pas grave l'assurance
plaira si vous aviez mis dans ma tête
vous avez mis dans la bagnole je serai
mort oui et en plus il y avait un
policier là qui voulait même pas nous
qui en avait rien à [ __ ]
il a sauté sur
[Applaudissements]
pour finaliser ça je suis venu donc
voilà c'est fini maintenant ouais j'ai
un disque à vendre
et le test de l'air c'est elle qui vous
avez agressé aussi bah ouais mais bon
comme je dis toujours hein c'est sans
obligation d'achat on or qu'est-ce qu'on
en veut puis ça change rien faut juste
savoir qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui quand
même il y a air France qui me demande
qu'à qui me demande de l'argent par
rapport à mon qui a gagné vu qu'elle a
quand même pour une gifle elle a pris 6
mois de congé maladie donc il y a un
manque à gagner de bosser pendant un an
et demi quoi
sécurité sociale qui me demande aussi de
l'argent ça veut dire que j'ai déjà ça
m'a déjà coûté 200000 balles un truc
comme ça 2300000 balles et là on m'en
demande encore 300 et tu l'avais jeté en
première parce que
je l'aurais déraillé pour ce prix là
pour ce prix là
vous allez faire mieux plus calme c'est
parce que vous avez un disque avant nous
parce que vous êtes fait soigner
pour Kirikou
fais gaffe quand même vous êtes amoureux
peut-être hein
non c'est pas ça c'est que je pense que
je pense qu'avant avant j'allais sur les
caractéristiques j'étais avec Kool shene
donc il y avait un côté illuminiang et
puis aujourd'hui je me retrouve tout
seul donc quelque part c'est à moi de le
jeu de l'agence
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu